muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en esta oportunidad nos
acompaña matías de stefano barbero él es
doctor en antropología miembro del
instituto de masculinidades y cambio
social y también de la asociación pablo
de son donde forma parte del equipo de
coordinación de espacios para varones
que ejercieron violencia es además autor
del libro masculinidad es imposible es
un libro sobre la compleja relación
entre masculinidades y violencias matías
muchísimas gracias por tu presencia en
la entrevista de france 24
ustedes matías comenzar por una pregunta
básica que es la masculinidad
bueno hay cierto debate de muchas
definiciones hay un poco en los libros
las trato pero creo que es una
aproximación sencilla sería pensar bueno
cuáles son los discursos vinculados a
los sentidos del ser hombre en nuestra
sociedad y bueno cuánto tienen que ver
esos discursos esas prácticas o sentidos
con el poder con la violencia con la
desigualdad también con la
heterosexualidad con la homofobia pero
también y un poco fuera del sentido
común con la vulnerabilidad con el miedo
muchas veces con el silencio con la
humillación con la vergüenza con todas
cosas que aparecen mucho en el libro
dominó absolutamente precisamente que
contamos en la audiencia que estábamos
viendo hasta recién en imágenes la
portada de tu libro ahora a matías vos
hablabas recientes discursos y prácticas
no que rodean a lo que es la
masculinidad y solemos vincular a veces
a la violencia con la masculinidad en tu
libro planteas que la violencia de
varones hacia mujeres hace parte de lo
que es un entramado a una red verdad y
tengo aquí dos preguntas matías qué rol
tiene la violencia en lo que es la
construcción de la más cool y por otra
parte hay una estructura social que
construye y alimenta esta violencia
bueno lamentablemente la violencia tiene
mucho que ver con la masculina para
forjar hombres
muchas veces se hace a través de la
violencia porque cuando cuando nacemos
si tenemos la capacidad todos los seres
humanos nos de la agresividad pero la
violencia en su entramado social tiene
en otras características entonces
hacerse hombre muchas veces tiene que
ver con reprimir toda una parte de
nuestra humanidad
que todas las personas cuando nacemos
tenemos la capacidad de expresar
emociones de llamar de forjar vínculos
comunitarios y sin embargo muchas veces
a los varones en nuestras sociedades se
les quita una parte de su humanidad para
que sean hombres de verdad no muchas
veces tiene que ver precisamente con el
silencio con el rechazo a la feminidad
por ese miedo a la homofobia muchas
veces
y lo que termina sucediendo
lamentablemente es que después los
varones esa violencia que sufrimos la
terminamos replicando muchas veces no
para pertenecer a esa estructura social
que nos premia de alguna manera si la
reproducimos y que nos castiga si vamos
en contra de ello muy interesante esta
suerte de proceso de deshumanización lo
que planteas ahora a matías en tu libro
contás lo que fue el disparador de tu
investigación que tuvo lugar en una
marcha de ni una menos en argentina no
en 2015 en marzo de 2015 cuando viste lo
contaste en el libro a una joven
sosteniendo un cartel que se preguntaba
cómo nace un femicida preguntarnos por
los varones se implica un cambio verdad
un cambio muy importante de hecho el
libro plantea la metáfora que hay que
volver a juan podría desarrollarla por
favor para nuestra agencia porque es muy
interesante
bueno en un poco la propuesta nace de un
ejercicio que hizo una lingüista
feminista julia penélope ella decía que
lo que empieza como una escena a la que
juan golpea maría a través de un proceso
lingüístico no lo dice maría fue
golpeada por juan luego mariah fue
golpeada y luego mariah es víctima de
violencia es como terminamos pensando
muchas veces la violencia de género no
maria víctima de violencia y no aparece
la pregunta por juan no es un propongo
es un poco la propuesta el libro es
volver a esa primera anunciación donde
juan golpea maria y preguntarnos por
juan como hacía la chica que vos
contabas en la manifestación y se
preguntaba bueno como se hace un
femicida buena o felicidad muchas veces
se hace con violencia también no porque
una persona no conoce la violencia por
primera vez cuando la ejerce no es un
proceso social como contaba antes lo que
tiene que ver con
y mutilación digamos de algunas de sus
partes de la humanidad luego puede ser
en la familia a través de sufrir
violencia familiar
como niños o ser testigos muchas veces
de violencia contra la madre y luego es
una violencia que aparece también en la
escuela del acoso escolar no aparece ya
esa jerarquía entre varones unos varones
por encima de otros pero también luego
con las mujeres no
dirigidas las mujeres
exactamente bueno un poco la propuesta
del libro es ver cómo se intersectan las
violencias en la vida de los varones que
ejercen violencia vamos a veces empiezan
siendo testigos o sufriendo las las
reproducen en la escuela cuanto de la
violencia que tiene que ver con la
homofobia en el acoso escolar luego
también tiene que ver con la violencia
que sufren las mujeres un poco la
propuesta es ver que la violencia no
está compartimental izada en las
personas sino que forma parte de su vida
no es un continuo presente de su vida
ahora una distinción clave y muy
interesante que plantearse en el libro
tiene que ver con que propone hablar de
violencia masculina hacia las mujeres no
sea de violencia machista patriarcal o
de violencia de género contános porque
esta elección a nivel conceptual
bueno es esto una discusión dentro del
libro y si tengo que decir que cada
concepto tiene sus posibilidades y tiene
sus limitaciones
a mí me parece que
lo bueno del concepto de violencia
masculina contra las mujeres es que
nombra
a quien ejerce la violencia y a quien la
sufre cuando nos referimos al tipo de
violencia que yo estudié en la
investigación y con la que trabajo y un
poco en la línea lo que decía antes esta
idea de cuánto tiene que ver la
violencia y el género lo tanto violencia
de género claro tiene que ver
precisamente con esto que nombraba antes
muchas veces la homofobia podría ser
considerada una violencia vinculada al
género porque tiene que ver con como los
varones nos expresamos en el mundo no
por miedo a sufrir homofobia no
mostramos
muchísimas de las cosas que sentimos por
ejemplo no decimos cosas que pensamos no
actuamos de determinadas maneras por
miedo a no ser leídos como varones
heterosexuales no haya sufrido homofobia
entonces es una forma de violencia que
también tiene que ver con el género con
esto sin invisibilizar por supuesto que
la violencia específica que sufren las
mujeres pero esta idea de ver cuánto del
género nos puede explicar determinadas
formas de violencia me hizo elegir
digamos ese concepto en la investigación
para mostrar digamos otras otras
potencialidades y otras particularidades
que tiene la violencia contra contra las
mujeres ahora continuando no en esta
línea de la violencia de varones contra
mujeres es muy común lamentablemente por
supuesto no conocer mujeres en nuestros
entornos que han sido violentadas por
parte de varones pero no solemos
escuchar hablar a amigos oa conocidos oa
conocidos de conocidos etcétera que sean
violentos no por lo menos manifestarse
de esta manera en tu trabajo con grupos
de hombres que ejercieron violencia
contra mujeres con que te encontraste
cuando comenzaste a ser parte de esos
grupos de esos debates y qué aprendizaje
estás obtenido
bueno muchas veces los varones nos
solemos hablar de nuestras relaciones de
pareja y mucho menos de las situaciones
conflictivas que podemos llegar a tener
con con nuestras parejas porque eso
también implica mostrarse vulnerable a
los otros varones no implica quizás
exponerse a formas de humillación a
formas de vergüenza incluso de violencia
entonces no tenemos la costumbre de
hablar de estas cuestiones y lo que pasa
un poco en los grupos es al principio un
poco con ese aprendizaje muchas veces
los varones las primeras sesiones les
cuesta mucho tomar la palabra porque
tienen un poco miedo también a las
consecuencias frente a otros varones que
puede llegar a tener lo que digan y lo
que van viendo también paulatinamente en
los grupos es que sus vulnerabilidades
no se usan para para humillarlos o para
violentar no sino precisamente
para trabajar con ellos los motivos de
estas situaciones de violencia el lugar
que ocupó la violencia en su vida muchas
veces es un trabajo donde se trabaja con
la violencia específicamente pero se
hace un trabajo adyacente también para
ver bueno cuanto de la violencia está
presente en sus vidas cuanto del miedo
cuanto del silencio sobre lo que sienten
tiene que ver también con el ejercicio
de violencia y esa búsqueda de poder que
muchas veces decimos que tienen los
varones no en sus relaciones de pareja
bueno muchas veces es un poder que no
tienen en el vínculo porque el vínculo
se transformó muchas veces y es
precisamente bueno cómo encarar esa
pérdida de poder y cómo habitar un lugar
de vulnerabilidad sin que eso suponga
tener que recurrir a la violencia no
poder sentirse más cómodo en la
vulnerabilidad es muchas veces parte del
trabajo que hacemos en la asociación
powers o algo también muy interesante
que sin matías es lo que tiene que ver
con lo que son las políticas de
intervención en estos casos no políticas
que como en tus libros suelen ser
positivistas y también individualistas
algo con respecto a lo cual vos o
bastante crítico no contamos por qué
bueno yo creo que muchas veces viene
viene asociada a la pregunta no si los
varones pueden cambiar yo creo que creo
que sí creo que todas las personas que
trabajamos con personas ejercen
violencia debemos creer que pueden
cambiar sino nuestro trabajo sería
inútil
y un poco también vinculado a estos
nombres del positivismo si consideramos
que los valores nos pueden cambiar la
única posibilidad es encerrarlos no es
recurrir a unity abismo yo creo que hay
otras vías creo que el positivismo puede
ser necesario en algunas situaciones
extremas pero creo y parte también del
trabajo que hacemos en la asociación es
confiar en que la transformación de las
personas es posible para que podamos
también devolverles el lugar en la
comunidad que tienen las personas que
pueden haber hecho daño no esto no se
reduce solamente a las órdenes que
ejercieron violencia lo digo también con
respecto a personas que cometieron otros
delitos no me parece que el imaginario
de nuestra sociedad lamentablemente cada
vez va cada vez va más hacia el
positivismo hacia la responsabilidad
individual que es buena duda existe pero
si tomamos en cuenta las condiciones en
las que se produce la violencia insisto
muchas veces a través del haber sufrido
la violencia
parecería un poco cínico devolverles
solamente
esa
posibilidad a las personas el castigo me
parece que tenemos que apuntar
socialmente hacia una sociedad que pueda
tener una justicia más reparatoria
y que apunte más a la transformación
social y menos al castigo y a la
separación y a la estigmatización como
la única vía posible de tratamiento de
algunos de estos problemas mattia de
stefano muchísimas gracias por esta
entrevista se pasó rapidísimas y un
placer dialogar contigo un placer de
santiago muchas gracias no gracias a ti
nuevamente en nuestra audiencia como
siempre le invitamos a continuar
informando se en el resto de nuestra
programación y en france24 punto com
sigan con nosotros
[Música]
y